democracy is messy is every day my life
is missing but if you want everything to
be quiet in orderly and allow you know
just things to proceed without vigorous
debate that is not what democracy is
about we are bringing in a lot of new
people into the political process people
who have never gone to a convention
before and they hope very much that
their voices will be heard do we open
the doors many many millions of people
often working class people people are
working maybe two or three jobs to make
ends meet to young people who have never
perhaps voted in their lives or do we
say hey you know you're not really one
of us we're too busy going to fancy
fundraisers and you're really not what
this party wants that's the choice
democracy is not always nice and quiet
and gentle but that is where the
democratic party should
you